let's see who else is on the line why
don't we try our caller from the four
four three area code taking calls seeing
what's on people's minds
four four three go ahead hey David how's
it going this is Brian first-time caller
it's fun to say thanks for the show that
you do it's great I just had a quick
question it may seem like a stupid
question but I when I think about it it
kind of seems like there's obviously
important who wants to answer to this so
hopefully you can help me out okay um I
was wondering if you could help me out
with a few is there any questions you
can ask someone to sort of figure out
what actual political affiliations they
are or what they closely identify with
because I feel like today a lot a lot of
people that would support Trump may
actually identify more with progressives
but just not know it so I was wondering
if there's a few questions that I could
maybe ask a family member who may or may
not be a Trump supporter you know these
questions to then prove to them that
they aren't actually a Republican that
they're actually a progressive or I mean
I know there's a lot of nuances with
with the different parties now but is
there anything that could actually
identify someone as a specific party
based on a few questions well there's
two different things there there's party
identification but then there's
political orientation so party
identification is just what party do you
identify with that's less interesting I
think the more interesting thing would
be are your political beliefs actually
not aligned with the party you think you
identify with so it didn't there's no
short list like if you ask people does
the government have some basic right
some basic duty to provide everybody
with some level of health care
regardless of whether they can pay for
it or not that is really popular that's
like 70 to 80 percent yes from the
country but only like 30-something
percent of Americans or registered
Democrats or even less and Republicans
aren't of that mindset so like there's a
literal mathematical incongruity there
that doesn't make sense
I think it's better to come up with ways
to ask political issue questions in a
nonpartisan way so like what I just said
was not do you believe in socialized
health care do you want rohtul
free-market like you if you use those
buzzwords people will get on the
defensive right away instead use
relatively neutral language like should
the government provide everybody some
basic health care whether or not they
can pay for it and when you start asking
questions in that way you will often
disarm people and hopefully get sort of
more more honest answers about what
their beliefs are yeah and I also think
you know it'll make people sort of
hopefully make people realize that
perhaps they're voting against their own
interests in a lot of cases that's
awesome well I appreciate thanks for
your answer I appreciate great thanks
thank you yeah I appreciate you calling
in